a woman who's got a low body count
who doesn't go out
and
who looks good
and it will get challenged you can't
have it both ways
challenge you can't have it
instead of listening to what we want
you have to challenge it and then you
get confused about why men straight so
like when she's saying men will go for a
younger woman
the stats are there that men are more
attracted to younger women
instead of looking at it and saying okay
well that's that's the just the truth of
the matter the same way short men accept
women like taller men
women need to accept that men have
certain standards
and that is what the facts are and the
thing is why is it that
when
when a woman tells a man this is what i
want the men gotta listen
but when the man is saying this is what
i want the woman like no no no no no no
no
no
no
i just don't give up i don't i don't
care she's like
it's not like
he is not the only man in this
world like they think in this way cool
like you're gonna find is 20 years old
girl okay give free child and whatever
but like we are setting that we are
setting that we just think in a
different way which is a completely
different thing but if the car we are
certainly who like
i like a six-foot guy and you are
setting it i'm fine with you getting
taken out at 20 years old girl you know
i think about that
at 53 i'm looking good i can get any man
i want you know why because i might have
a low body cat but i'm going to be what
all the men want you know what i mean
rubbish
rubbish exactly
i look like this she's less than 15
minutes she's less than 15. you know out
there it's rubbish this is
and you can't get blood out of a stone i
don't care how good i look you can't
breathe after a certain amount if you're
gonna say oh yeah the she could have a
baby at 40. yeah you want to go and be
in the playground 65. they're all women
in school
but the women don't want children but
it's what they're doing one might one
mike one minute it's what the men want
and the women are not listening to when
they're mental but men somehow have to
shut up and listen to where women are
talking about you i'm not telling about
what you want when the man's telling you
what i want a man saying this is what i
want and the woman like nah nah nah nah
nah you don't want it because i'm all
this
or or no no
or the other ways they say they don't
care but if you're selling a car
you have to study the people you're
selling to
and you don't go up to the people that
are buying and say oh you should want me
this is what you should want go ahead
the point i'm trying to make is you're
it's like you're assuming that you're
putting me in the box of people that are
saying oh no you can't want that because
i'm this way have me as i am i never
said that i said no i said people should
go for what they want if you want a 20
something year old woman go for that 20
sovereign woman that wants a 40 30 year
old man if there's a 30 year old woman
or whatever who can't have kids or
doesn't want to have kids or
is too old to have kids or whatever and
she meets someone that is happy to have
her then that's like it shouldn't be a
combative thing where it's like women
don't listen and and men listen and
shouldn't should have to settle and
should have to listen to what women want
blah blah if there's a man that is four
for eight and he wants a tall woman and
the woman doesn't want him he has to
accept it if there's a woman that's 37
38 and there's a guy who's earning a lot
of money ticks or boxes he doesn't want
her because she's old just to accept it
that's the point that i was trying to
say in the beginning was
would you blame a man for stepping out
if you had given
somebody else your best years and this
is why the men were saying what the best
years are but the women do not want to
hear from the men what the best years
are and when it comes to what the best
the best years for the men
biology takes a main part of it so it
doesn't matter how old you guys matter
and
you guys were arguing about what the
best years were because you said gave
your best years to someone else that's
where i was a bit what do you mean gave
my best yeah it's not just the success
experience it's the it's that whole
especially when you've had a child for
someone else especially
i will say majority of men legacy is
very important do not yes that's a lot
of baby mamas around okay okay hold on
hold on and then this falls in with the
age thing as well because as we were
saying the older you're getting the more
barren you're becoming so then because
you're older you should accept that a
man will cheat on you is that is that
what we're saying
that's the point guys like not every
women need a man like it doesn't want to
step out step out like when we are 30
that's my value when you say oh you know
20 anymore so you don't have any value
no i actually my value is that i can
stand by my own i can pay my bills i'm
independent and this is because i'm 30
because when i was 20 i was probably
looking for a man to you know help me
out in you know just to in order to you
know are you going to be happy 60
without a family by yourself yeah
because in in the world i can do a lot
of things i can travel i can i can if i
cannot have my own baby i can adopt it i
can have a pet i can do whatever else
i'm not just a bloody baby machine
honestly i'm not i'm not a baby machine
so my value it doesn't depend from how
many eggs i uh steal from children
though i don't know i still don't i'd
never found a man that let me think okay
let's have a baby still so if in i don't
know i don't i don't wanna have a child
i don't think my life's gonna be sad
you're saying you want you want children
with the right man
it has to be the right man of course i'm
30 now right so about what i want to say
is that if you find the right man
right at 35
you get in the relationship at 35
when are you going to think about having
a child i don't know that can happen in
six months that can happen in two years
time that's not uh you know calendar and
we don't planify our life day by day
that things just happens and i just
don't feel like i'm less vulnerable than
20 years old i'm just different you know
did you know one out of three women
under 30 have fertility issues one out
of everything
our food is different today so so said i
don't leave a knife i want to tell you
so like so i i know but i'm saying for
the right guy so if you found the guy
that that you would have a kid with like
that that's more of a risk when you're
older yeah but he's free to go without
20 years old if he's just won't think
about me as a baby machine it's free to
go either 20 years old but one girl i'm
fine
i'm just functioning about my age i'm
happy
yeah we're talking about baby right now
so i just answered the question your
value
my value i'll explain to you i explained
to you just now that my value is not
about how many when men i slept with
it's not about how many eggs i contain
still because i'm not a baby machine my
value is about how many money i can make
because i probably can make more money
than men out there
is about how what i can deal with life
every day i don't need a man this is my
value okay i stand by my own this is my
value so the question is can you find a
man that can stand next to me and deal
with me yeah but when you say that's
your value to him but who's that yeah
for me i don't i don't know
like when you're selling something she's
talking about cars when you're selling
something it's you you decide the value
of your